Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. We've got another first
look at Venom 3 to break down
It seems like it's going to be somewhere
near the opening scene,
If it's not the opening scene, and
I know a lot of you've been asking
about the actual Spider-Man of all these Sony
spin off movies that they've been doing.
Because there were a lot of deleted scenes of them
trying to put the symbiote on Tom Holland
during Spider-Man no way home.
So clearly they were trying at the time And Tom Hardy
has revealed
that this is probably the end of the Venom solo movies.
be calling it Venom Last Dance, even though
the title of the movie will be a little bit different,
Probably going to wind up being lethal protector.
But it definitely seems like
Sony is trying to make Tom Holland
the live action Spider-Man
of all these Sony spin off movies.
and it seems like they've been relying
on a lot of the stuff that Marvel
has been doing with the multiverse,
especially what happened in the Loki
series, tying
everything in the multiverse in general together.
I know was a ton of questions.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all of the videos.
This year.
In the next couple of years,
we're going to be like Peak Spider-Man.
There are like four Spider-Man movies
and shows coming out this year.
Then beyond the Spider-Verse
Tom Holland's Spider-Man for 2025 26.
So Spider-Man fans are going to be eating good
for the next couple of years.
but during the footage you see them filming a new venom
three scene with Eddie in Los Mateo's Spain
what might be going on here is they might just be
filming in Spain and it might be doubling for Mexico.
And he's still in Mexico
after the events of the last movie.
during the movie, he's
meant to be on the run since the end of Venom.
Let there be carnage in the Spider-Man
No Way Home Post-Credits scene.
at the end of Venom, let there be carnage.
He fled the United States to Mexico.
That's where the hotel room,
the scene on the beach was supposed to be.
And then he was transported to the MCU universe
version, the hotel room by Doctor Strange.
His first spell during the Spider-Man
No Way home post-credits scene.
He just walked from that room
with the very surprised random dude to the hotel bar.
Getting super drunk, talking to Cristo Fernandez,
the bartender, about everything
that had happened in the MCU up to that point,
they recapped the events of the MCU
through Avengers Infinity War, Avengers Endgame
with Thanos, the Snap, even Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
most people remember him as Danny Rojas from Ted Lasso.
The fact that they were talking about Spider-Man
is a little bit funny because obviously it's Venom.
So they want Venom to be thinking about Spider-Man
like he was on his way to New York City
to talk to Spider-Man, that they were going to face
each other before Doctor Strange.
His second spell
transported him back to his venom Universe.
what it looks like Sony is doing
is they're trying to set up Tom Holland's Spider-Man
as their main live action Spider-Man, even though
I think that is just one of their contingency plans,
I don't think it's actually going to go down this way.
Technically, they still own the movie
rights to the character like Sony owns Spider-Man.
They just continue to share him with Marvel.
One movie at a time in a couple of spinoffs,
but the deals
that they make are really only for that one solo movie.
Marvel's current contract with them
extends to Avengers five,
but that's considered more of a cameo level role.
Sony's had mixed results with all their Spider-Man
spin off movies and they definitely want to supercharge
those They have this Sinister Six separate franchise
they're trying to set up.
They kind of do that in the Morbius Post-Credits scene.
there were all those Spider-Man Easter eggs
that they tried to work into the Morbius movie
then took out at the last minute.
It sounds like a lot of that was in service
of not hurting the performance of Spider-Man
No Way Home
because it was doing so well at the box office.
But right now.
The Venom movies are their biggest box office earners,
and they're not going to be doing
any more Venom solo movies
after Venom three, apparently, according to Tom Hardy.
So they need to do something to legitimize
this separate
Sony's Spider-Man universe,
this Venom universe that they created.
And that would be introducing
a live action version of Spider-Man.
Normally, I would love to say that
it's going to be Andrew Garfield or Tobey Maguire,
but it just sounds like everything they've been doing,
trying to connect this to the Marvel Universe is so
that Tom Holland can become
that main Spider-Man for their universe.
but I think that's really just meant to be
one of their contingency plans.
Like there is a symbiote saga that Marvel has planned
for Spider-Man, but it won't be Spider-Man four.
I think they're saving Spider-Man symbiote
for like Spider-Man five or Spider-Man six.
However, many more movies Tom Holland
winds up doing eventually, if those do work out.
Right.
Now, Spider-Man
four is supposed to be more of a friendly neighborhood,
ground level Spider-Man
kind of movie, like taking him back to basics.
That's where there's been all this talk about him
crossing over with the daredevil characters,
with the Kingpin character.
So if we see Spider-Man Symbiote Saga teasers,
I don't think that will be too
like the very end of the movie.
Like, yeah, by the way, there's this piece
of the symbiote this like slowly making his way to New
York City because remember, it was down in Mexico
the last time we saw the symbiote.
is one of those little teasers that it sounds like
Sony is keeping in their back pocket,
just like just in case things fall out with Marvel.
And we want to take the character back.
We have this Spider-Man symbiote saga
that we're going to launch
right now the rumor about the plot
is the real main villain of the movie is actually going
to be a version of the Xeno Phage,
which is a race of cultures in the Marvel Comics
that feed off the symbiotes like natural predators
to the symbiotes and for the most part, the only real
natural predator that Symbiotes is actually
no God of Symbiotes They're meant to be apex predators.
So someone that can actually take them
down is meant to be really, really powerful.
there have been a couple of deleted scenes
and a couple of references to Noelle, but obviously no
is going to be a big character. During Venom three.
he be like an endgame.
Thanos Level threat for the Venom characters,
they wouldn't go straight to that.
In a trilogy.
You say that for like some giant, huge universe
crossover the report right now is that during
the movie, the xeno phage won't be from another planet
like the Symbiotes as it is in the comics.
It'll be the result of the government's
genetic experimentation on the symbiotes
in the previous movies
to create their own anti-venom type of symbiote weapon.
But it won't literally be anti-venom from the comics,
which is like a totally different character.
Anti-Venom was created when Eddie Brock is separated
from the Venom symbiote briefly.
It left traces of the symbiote in his body.
He developed cancer and then went to one of Martin
Lee's feast shelters for help,
which they featured in the Spider-Man games.
they've been featured on Maze, these shelters
during Spider-Man, No Way home briefly.
What? Eddie Brock was there.
Martin Lee used his Mr.
Negative Powers to cure Eddie's cancer,
but the process also caused the symbiote traces
in his body to change and bond with his white blood
cells, creating a new hybrid anti-venom symbiote
It manifested fully for the first time when the regular
venom symbiote tried to bond with his body again
all of his powers as you would
expect, were mostly healing based
in addition to regular enhance attributes
that all symbiotes give people.
it can cure any disease,
any impurity in his body or other people's bodies.
And it's completely mindless,
unlike the regular symbiotes.
So when Eddie Brock is wearing the anti-venom symbiote,
he's fully in control.
they might eventually have some Easter eggs
for anti-venom in the Venom movies,
but I don't think they have any plans
to completely separate Eddie Brock
permanently or semi permanently from the Venom
symbiote.
They've already done the symbiote body swapping trick
a couple of times in the movies like within Waiting
Lady Venom There are also rumors
that Patrick Mulligan will return as a version of talks
and as a lot of people assumed after Venom, Let there
be carnage because of the ending with his character.
he got
the toxin symbiote as a result of their final fight.
reportedly that character will go on to become another
anti-hero symbiote like Toxin does in the comics.
And he and Venom want the team up to stop xeno phage
who will be the true villain of the movie
in after that toxin
which is going to continue being an anti-hero
in the universe on his own,
which is pretty much how things go in the comics.
but toxins history is
these are relatively new character.
He wasn't introduced till 2004 during a Venom versus
Carnage storyline.
so circle of life.
The carnage symbiote realizes
that it had been pregnant.
It was about to spawn another symbiote.
But it hated the idea of toxin before it was ever born
because it was his prophecy
that the thousandth iteration of their lineage,
the toxin symbiote,
would become way more powerful than any of them before.
carnage hates
the idea of toxin even more than it hates venom.
What a happy family.
Because you have to remember that
venom is kind of like toxins.
Grandfather.
It made a plan to kill toxin as soon as it spawned it.
So it's like killing your child right after it's born.
but the spawning process left him so weak
that he couldn't do anything about it
but because Patrick Mulligan just happens to be nearby
it puts the toxin
symbiote into him
is sort of a temporary holding vessel saying that
he'll come back
when he regained his strength to kill both of them.
so carnage didn't give Mulligan the toxin symbiote
because he cared about him or he trusted him.
He was using him more like a tool, like a plaything.
then when carnage does become strong enough,
a bunch of other characters stop him from killing toxin
Venom actually stops him, hoping
that he can train toxin to fight Spider-Man
and Carnage he's also responsible
for naming the new symbiote toxin.
He calls them toxin because his symbiote smells
poisonous to the other symbiotes.
but he has all their abilities, just turned up to 11
so he can do all the same things that carnage can do,
the venom can do, but just more Later it's revealed
that Mulligan has a strong enough personality
and sense of morality to show carnage, mercy
when they fight so venom and carnage,
then realize that it's possible
toxin could eventually turn good
and team up with Spider-Man against them,
which obviously they don't want.
So then Venom and Carnage try to team up to kill Toxin
like I said, those three symbiotes
relationship is very complicated.
eventually Peter Parker.
Spider-Man does help toxin during the fight, realizing
what's going on
and then gives Mulligan
the same version of the Uncle Ben speech.
With great power comes great responsibility in.
Mulligan walks away, spending his early days as talks
and trying to teach the symbiote how to be good.
It's a little bit what you saw
at the end of the first Venom movie with Eddie
trying to teach the Venom symbiote how to be good.
let me know in the comments, though, when do you
actually want them to do this Spider-Man symbiote saga?
I think if everything works out,
they'll actually just do that during Avengers
Secret Wars
because they can be a little bit more like the comics.
Even though their movie version of Secret Wars
will be very different from the comics, they could do
some Easter eggs from the comics like Spider-Man
Getting the Black Suit during Secret Wars.
Doesn't It just makes sense to wait
till then to actually give him the suit
because that's going to be well after Spider-Man four.
So you can do your friendly neighborhood
ground level Spider-Man with Daredevil, with Kingpin,
those are the characters.
Then you can actually do symbiote stuff.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
We'll probably get some more Madame Web footage
pretty soon.
Really interesting to see how they tie
that to the multiverse in a definitely
seems like it's going to rely on Loki in his multiverse
tree, like they're slowly using the of web character
to pull all these characters together inside their Sony
Spider-Man universe.
we're probably going to get that Deadpool
three trailer at the Super Bowl.
So of course I'll post the video for it
as soon as they release it.
it will probably get new Kraven Trailers in Venom,
three trailers after Matt and Web
comes out in theaters.
So click here for that brand new Deadpool
3 teaser trailer and click here
to learn about the Punisher coming back in
all the Marvel Netflix defenders characters.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!